On se rend compte que
sous la pelouse de Chantilly,
existe la pierre utilisée à l'époque,
la pierre de Saint-Maximin.
Des pierres à 100 m de la porte des grandes
écuries, une source naturelle de pierres,
mais gigantesque, deux hectares et demi
de pierre à tailler dans le brut,
pour un bâtiment telles les grandes écuries,
c'est formidable.
Aussi incroyable que cela puisse paraître,
sous les grandes écuries,
se cache un labyrinthe aussi grand
que 3 terrains de football.
À l'époque, ce n'est pas moins
de 50 000 blocs de pierre,
qui vont être extraits par
ces grands trous creusés dans la roche.
Ces cheminées ont deux fonctions.
La première les flux d'air,
et puis la deuxième,
c'est aussi l'extraction des pierres,
puisqu'on y mettait des pièces
de bois et charpentes.
Et avec un système de poulies,
on remontait les pierres à la surface.
C'est à la fois un gain
de temps et un gain d'argent.
Parce que dans un budget de construction d'un
bâtiment comme celui des grandes écuries,
la part de l'achat de la pierre mais aussi
de son acheminement est considérable.
Ce n'est pas le seul avantage dont
les bâtisseurs vont bénéficier,
et notamment lors de la construction
de la pièce maîtresse des écuries.
Le dôme a des dimensions exceptionnelles.
Il fait 28 mètres de haut à l'intérieur,
sur 20 mètres de large.
C'est un chef-d'œuvre
de la taille de pierre.
Mais les constructeurs français
sont très forts, très habiles.
Ils maîtrisent la technologie.
Un savoir-faire indéniable, mais qui
va nécessiter certains ajustements,
en raison de la taille XXL du dôme.
C'est ce que nous explique
Jean-Michel Bouchard,
compagnon tailleur de pierre
et meilleur ouvrier de France.
Quand on fait un dôme à 28 mètres
sur une dimension comme ça,
il faut contrecarrer les poussées
de ces pierres qu'on met.
On met plusieurs tonnes
de pierres, on les clave,
on taille tous les cailloux
à une certaine forme,
pour que les poussées verticales
soient repoussées en horizontale,
qu'elles partent
en oblique et qu'à la fin,
elles redescendent dans
les murs de chaque côté.
5 m d'épaisseur, pour contrebalancer
la poussée de ces voûtes.
La prouesse architecturale,
en quelque sorte, là-dedans,
c'est qu'on n'a pas l'impression d'avoir des
murs plus épais que dans un autre château.
Pour s'assurer que
le dôme ne s'écroule pas,
les ouvriers vont également
ajouter un autre matériau, le métal.
Les constructeurs avaient la prudence
d'introduire des éléments métalliques,
qui peut être à l'assemblage
entre les pierres,
pour renforcer la tenue
mécanique de l'ensemble.
Des prouesses architecturales
d'autant plus exceptionnelles,
qu'elles sont réalisées dans
des conditions de travail épouvantables.
On sait par exemple que le prince
de Condé paye un chirurgien sur place,
pour s'occuper des ouvriers blessés.
On a aussi des témoignages
d'accidents de chantier,
des échafaudages qui
s'effondrent avec les ouvriers dessus,
et avec évidemment, des blessés.
Mais il y a pire, les ouvriers doivent
faire face à une menace inattendue.
Nicole Garnier est la conservatrice
en chef du domaine de Chantilly.
Lors de travaux de rénovation en 2008,
elle et ses équipes ont
fait une macabre découverte.
On a trouvé ce crâne humain
qui a été transmis à la gendarmerie,
qui a fait les analyses nécessaires.
Visiblement, il s'agit d'un homicide
puisqu'il y a une trace de balle,
qui ressort de l'autre côté.
L'analyse au carbone 14
qui a été faite par les gendarmes,
a indiqué que cet homme
ou cette femme, on ignore le sexe,
a été tué entre 1650 et 1950.
D'après certaines archives,
ce crâne pourrait être celui de l'un
des ouvriers du chantier des grandes écuries.
Une des hypothèses,
c'est effectivement le comte de Charolais,
qui était le gestionnaire du domaine,
et dont on sait qu'il a tué certains des
ouvriers qui travaillaient sur ses terres.
Il utilisait les ouvriers de toiture
pour s'entraîner au tir.
En tout cas, ça fait partie
des nombreuses légendes de Chantilly,
et notamment des légendes
noires de Chantilly.